fighter in the kids that malik is a liar
malek is uh
you know negative malik is the butt of
the joke no i know how to play off
comedy
you know but you know when they get out
there and just say like now they got
fired and they put that in people's
heads it's not what happened they're not
that's not what yeah
you know and here's the thing bro i'm
professional at all times
you know even with the you go back to
the clip where i said i talked to pbc
right and i just you know and and
brennan didn't believe me
you know like i'm lying or something
like that i just
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
i got this [ __ ] here malik b
sitting like a three-year-old
this is where you guys sit in the line
boy girl boy girl your teacher
all right mallet come on yeah i gotta
sit right back down i don't even
remember this my legs when's the last
time you sat [ __ ] crisscross
applesauce
i don't know duck duck goose i don't
know man even at duck duck goose you had
to sit down
oh man hey bro man i haven't seen you
what in like about a month or so come on
man i got my legs out
i know you're gonna say something nah
man it's just funny because like back in
the day i remember when we were kids
like anybody who wore shorts above their
kneecaps they were either called gay go
ahead they got the ass beat
yeah and now that's the [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ] now
bro these not even shorts these like
shrimp swimming trunks i'm like
i was like how high can i go hey man
it's funny because so i uh if you guys
don't know i came
in a feature on the fire and the kid and
you know like i definitely clicked with
you a lot you know we came on
i came on the cutting weight podcast if
you haven't checked that out it's just
[ __ ] dope
um yeah and it's weird too i feel like
sometimes when you meet people like you
don't you don't really
know who they are right but then
sometimes when you're kind of cut from
the same clock you have a conversation
it's like
oh i could [ __ ] with this guy right and
i felt like with you i was like yo i got
to get this dude on the podcast and kind
of hear your story because when i was on
the fire in the kid i didn't get to hear
[ __ ] from you
like you never you you never spoke on
that [ __ ] podcast
i was in there like [ __ ] get out i
was like
i mean look people are people are gonna
ask either way so it's like as of right
now like i didn't bring
uh malik on the podcast to talk about
this but you you know everybody wants to
know
obviously you're not on the fire and the
kid anymore right
uh something happened in between
whatever you want to talk about and keep
it comfortable but
obviously there was a there was a split
people are blowing up my [ __ ] it's like
oh you're gonna have malecon
you gotta ask him about stuff but uh so
so what's going on with that
he text me he was like bro what the hell
is going on yeah i was like
why is everybody blowing up my [ __ ] yeah
nah um
but just get into it um it wasn't a
firing it was just a departure
okay you know and it was some you know
something that you know
brittany wanted me agreed to it and i
didn't i didn't know i didn't like those
terms
you know i'm not about to do anything i
don't do anything for money
you know i have principles i have value
so
um basically to getting gist of it it's
just like look
man like i'm just trying to revamp my
name you know like i get on fighting the
kids and
malik is a liar malek is uh you know
negative malik is the butt of the joke
no
i know how to play off comedy you know
but you know when they get out there and
just say like now they got fired and
they put that in people's heads it's not
what happened they're not that's not
yeah so you know and here's the thing
bro i'm a professional at all times
you know even with the you go back to
the clip where i said i talked to pbc
right and i just you know and and
brennan didn't believe me you know like
i'm lying or something like that
i just stayed focused and started
laughing because i was like look at this
dude
yeah and it comes out that pbc i talk to
pvc all the time
yeah the people that know that's a
boxing that's what al haymon i come from
that world
you know and um just just the whole gist
of it is just like man you know
you know that that you're talking about
so you know for me
people are sending me this stuff right
they sent me yeah they sent me this clip
and
i think it's the clip that you're
talking about right it's like
if you guys don't watch the fire in the
kid right so i've i've watched a lot of
brenda's shop stuff like i've seen him
on joe rogan [ __ ] i love them on joe
rogan and everything else but
there's there's a constant trope on the
fire in the kit where people like to
clown on brent a lot
and so they sent me this clip of you it
was it was a discrepancy between you
guys talking about whether it was
something was
pay-per-view or not that's pvc uh pbc
right yeah and then he was he was saying
that it wasn't
and then you say it is they just zoomed
it on his face
and he looked pissed off as [ __ ] or
something i don't know what that was oh
that [ __ ] made me laugh i was like damn
dude like people really go in on this
guy
they're really going on brendan man they
send me clips all the time but i was
like you know
it's uh it's very funny but but
i don't want to talk about that i just
want to talk about like you know the the
stuff
behind the scenes yeah and i'll and i'll
address
more about it on the podcast because i
can say whatever i want
you know and uh i didn't want to sign
those agreements i don't i'm not
a yes man i don't
i don't really dictate my future or my
career on
somebody else's terms okay so i i rather
battle myself i stand up on my man i
don't live on my knees
yeah you know and um basically you you
let's i have text from him and in the
middle of the night i'll be like yo
you know he tells me i'm off tour like
damn i prepared all week
for you know this show and then on
monday you text me i see you
you know face to face and i if i have
any issue i tell
everyone knows my rep i said to your
face i'm like bro i have a problem with
you
you know as a man that's how i was
conducting myself that's how i was
raised
i talked to people if i have an issue i
talk to you know straight directly
towards you i don't do over text
i don't do over the phone i don't do
none of that so
that's what the code i live by and
that's what i stand for
so you know it's just just
so much stuff i can just say and i will
say
but right now i just i'm not on fighter
in the kids
because i didn't want to agree to those
kind of terms that he set
and i'm like some people can i don't you
know and that's them
was was so it was it kind of like
because you didn't want to agree to
these terms did that
did that sour the relationship or was it
like sour before and this was like the
kind of
the straw that broke the camel's hump
because you know we people don't know
stuff behind scenes right we don't know
what real friendships are we don't know
what these personal relationships and
even for me
i'm not gonna say anything bad about
brendan because i don't know brendan
like that
you know like that's that's not i can't
i don't know him right so this is just a
story that i'm hearing and this is just
going to be one side of the story
but for you guys for for you anyways
like
for i mean this is it for me like it
kind of sucks when i see like
relationships break from something that
could be very uh
fruitful right and it happens a lot in
industry
where sometimes things get like business
and friendship always gets mixed up
and it makes me sad sometimes when i see
that because it's like
a lot of people have this thing it's
called scarcity mentality where
everybody doesn't for some reason people
don't believe that everybody can eat
like everybody can eat just because i'm
doing well doesn't mean you can't do
well either
and sometimes when it happens with like
a group of friends or
not saying that this is the fighter and
the kids but people who come into
entertainment and do things for fun when
money gets involved sometimes [ __ ] gets
a little funny
because people start to feel entitled to
their certain success
and for me personally when i when i've
worked with all my friends i've
the only time i've ever had a bad
business dealing is when i went to
business people who weren't friends
which is kind of crazy because people
usually tell you the opposite yeah like
don't ever do business with friends
but the people that i've done business
with i've been friends with 10 years
i've never had a single problem with
them
we now have a successful matcha
franchise
we're opening our we opened up our
fourth store we have
another one opening up real soon we have
we have four more opening up within this
year
and never had a problem an issue with
that and i think the biggest thing that
i found out too was
the people that you work with too you
really do have to be cut from the same
cloth
these dudes that i roll with if when we
talk about our background how we grew up
where we're from the [ __ ] that we dealt
with it's all the same
we dealt with [ __ ] being broke as
[ __ ]
yeah having our parents beat our [ __ ]
ass there was
there was consequences for lying there's
consequences for snitching
yeah and so for us because we live by
the same code we never had to re-up
on what these values are it's like yo i
know for a fact that this dude will
always have my back
right so for example let's say um and we
were talking about this earlier how
sometimes in this city
people don't live by the same code that
you and i probably live with right
and i've gotten to understand that
because majority of people when they
come to los
angeles they're expecting for a come-up
and they'll do whatever they can
whether they have to step on somebody's
neck or back to get to that spot it
doesn't matter
what what what the relationship is if
you [ __ ] with my bread
then you're [ __ ] out i don't really
function like that because
i i come up with like hey if i come up
you got to come up with me
because if not then what's the whole
point of being on top and being by
yourself
being on top of being alone sucks when
your friends come up with you it feels
really good that's why i started these
businesses with people so
for example let's say you and i like
years from now you and i are [ __ ]
tight we're friends
i hear somebody coming out and they go
hey yo i heard malik does this and that
i'm like don't talk to me about that
[ __ ] that's my boy
so you know whatever you have feelings
about him i understand you could talk
about it but don't talk to me about it
we could still be cool but you can't
talk about my boy a lot of people don't
function like that in the city
and it's so weird and that's so weird
yeah and and again well i i met a couple
of people out here and
you're right but i say i say in this
industry yeah
you know um yeah definitely like in the
industry like the entertainment
exactly entertainment of course because
let's be honest we know a lot of people
do anything for money yeah
success or fame and they will lose their
principal and their values and i wasn't
cut like that
and i i will it will hurt it will burn
if i you know don't stand on my word or
don't
be a man of my word i'll just stand on
my own ten toes and just like no this is
not right
and i i accept that no and and for the
listeners and the viewers
this is not a bashing a brenden shot
it's not
it's trying to tell you like malik is
like i'm i tell the truth all the time
and if p and if he feel like oh he can
go bash me and all that
i tell him bash me tell them it's no
proof
of malik just you know anything
everything i did is i'm a man of my word
i say what i mean
i do what i i tell you i'm going to do
and and they know that
everyone knows that so it's not like i'm
bitter or stuff like that no
yeah i'm happy i feel good not being
suffocated anymore
you know and that's the whole thing
about it so when you say
uh you feel better when it's your
friends come up
i have a friend justin you know um
everywhere i went i took him with me he
can he could attest to this
everyone jeff garlin i was like hey man
jeff garlin saw me
like grinding i'm a grinder open mics
every night and he was like i like that
and he i was like hey if you like me
you're gonna love my guy
brian calling i used to open a lot of
people don't know that when i was on
fighter in the kids
i wasn't trying to replace brian i used
to feature for brian yeah he saw me he
was like bro something about this kid
because i work hard so he's you can't
talk about my work yet because i was
like yo
that's like to me that's like the the
goat yeah yeah you know
so uh i and with brian kyle's like hey
bro i got i got a friend
justin elliott and he would with brendan
shop i was like hey yo thank you for
bringing me on two hey i got a friend
justin ellie so you want to
bring your guys up of course so it's up
to him to
make that decision like yo i want to
okay cool i appreciate that i appreciate
that he has to work hard
yeah if someone vouches for you you have
to prove don't make me look bad
oh 100 percent that's the word but
that's your friend you know he works
hard
so i just try to put as much like many
people
i can on because a lot of people you
know they don't get opportunities like
this and i know it's
like a crab and a bucket mentality but i
was like yo you it's not like that
it's hollywood a lot of people can eat
out here 100 just just stop thinking
like that like here's a new
i've seen guys blow up on instagram now
they're in movies i've seen guys blow up
on youtube
now they're it's just create your own
content your own lane
you don't have to dictate it's it's kind
of crazy because a lot of people don't
think that right so
sometimes people feel that somebody
else's success takes away from them
and it sucks right yeah but those are
people who are also not
very confident in their own skills right
because
let's say for me right like i have a
friend who i don't know we let's say i
started a podcast with a friend
who nobody [ __ ] knows right and i'm
like but he's funny and we're gonna
we're gonna do this podcast together
obviously i'll start it up and then i'll
pay him a check or whatever well if he
gets big
bigger and bigger and bigger he starts
his own podcast i'm not gonna feel a
certain way i'm gonna be like that's
[ __ ] dope
i'm glad people know who he is and now
he could pave his own way
you know then if he can't be on my
podcast because he wants to start his
own thing
be my guest man i'm glad you're
successful we'll i'll figure something
else out
and i feel like a lot of people should
have that mentality because at the end
of the day
you can always bet on yourself if you're
that [ __ ] good
be scared too though they don't want to
take that risk betting on yourself
yeah it's a lie because you understand
the odds are stacked against you
but once you prove to yourself like bro
i don't care what eyes against me
i'm still going to be successful if you
have that mentality you have your mind
made up you
you don't know what will happen but
again guys you can't
i can't force that in you it has to be
in you yeah you know and
again like some guys i know some guys
want to live on their knees i mean i
accept whatever they give me
do you feel like a lot of your your
mentality probably comes from your
your your boxing career because i know a
lot of like people who played
not played i'm sorry a lot of people
who've well that played football
like and they did wrestling and all
these like extreme sports
boxing and stuff contact sports they
seem to like take this mentality apply
it elsewhere too right
because i've i've only like probably
trained boxing in the last year and that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] sucks that [ __ ] is so
painful man let me tell you this man
like so i did a i did a
boxing session with uh my guy savant
young right
okay former pro fighter um everything
else great great coach
and he was like yo come and do some work
and then let's see if you want to work
let me tell you something man this guy
had me [ __ ] in that [ __ ] ring just
just do he goes
no jabs and i just want you to move your
feet i want to see how you move
i want you to throw faints don't throw
jabs don't throw crosses whatever
that five minutes i threw up that [ __ ]
was yeah you go five not three
that [ __ ] was exhausting maybe it might
have been one minute but your boy fat as
[ __ ]
and i'm like this is what a fighter has
to go through yeah like are you [ __ ]
kidding me yeah i didn't throw a single
punch
and i'm exhausted and then we did round
after round he goes all right next round
you're just going to shadow
box and then you're going to throw your
punches but i want to see you move in
and out i want to see you [ __ ] roll i
want to see you
put the defense in your shadow boxing as
well i threw up in my mouth again
and he was like cool you could take a
break and that breaks like a minute and
that minute went by like that oh it's 30
seconds in the gym
yeah it was like yo this is what boxers
have to go through like
this is rough and i feel like with that
mentality you could kind of
pursue anything if you could be in that
physical state
where you're throwing up in your mouth
all the time and i even thought punches
it makes me really respect boxers a lot
you know i
i love boxing and to your point i think
to just basically have a backbone
box you have to be a boxer but i think
it's more my mentality is more coming
from my dad and
and my dad was just like a stand-up guy
and
i was like he raised me to be that and
also just being
from baton rouge louisiana in my
neighborhood i wasn't the best i wasn't
the most talented
i just wanted to prove in them like nah
i'm good i'm good so it's just that
mentality of
of oh i know i'm is is people out there
better than me but i'm gonna work harder
than everyone
yeah and and then i started working
harder and then oh this is like oh malik
is the best in the neighborhood you
always wanted to
and that's the mentality though like you
know oh like that's how we click because
we're talking about oh you're so
spiteful you you know if someone says
you can't do something
oh i can't do it i'ma prove to you i can
do it just to show you you said i can't
do it yeah and that's the mentality
that i think we both have and i was
that's attracting
attracted me towards you but uh uh
boxing
it played a major part but i say
majority
is my pops how he was raised and how he
raised me
and just like bro you know if you take
anything you know
don't be surprised yeah yeah yeah that
that hard working mentality is sometimes
so i put out this tweet not too long ago
where i said that it sometimes sucks
but when you work really hard for the
things that you have in life and people
say the only reason why you're at where
you're at is because you're lucky
and that [ __ ] bothers me a lot right
because luck always has a part in
in your success right but that's not the
whole [ __ ] picture
like you weren't there for the grind you
weren't there when i was putting hours
and hours of work in right
but then you go okay well you're lucky
it's like well there's a lot of people
who are lucky just like me but they
didn't capitalize on the opportunity
that's the difference right and you know
people got in their feelings about that
yo david there's some people out there
who were just as hard as you that didn't
get to where you're at
i was like well that's because they
didn't work as hard as me that's what it
is that's how you cancel this situation
yeah in the argument yeah that's really
what it is i'm not saying that same
level of success but anybody who is the
hardest person working in the room
they always reach some level of success
i've yet to see otherwise
i've never seen it right yeah and some
people kind of think they kind of
misconstrue hard work
with doing stupid work so it's like yeah
you could be the person that [ __ ] um
that digs a whole constant and look for
this pot of gold but if the pot of gold
is in that other hole next to you
yeah you're a hard worker but you're
still not going to get the riches on the
other side
exactly so great you're a hard worker
but you didn't work smart you didn't use
this [ __ ] here thank you
so thank you people don't understand
that glad you said that yeah yeah you're
gonna work hard
but you got to work smart yeah if you
were working hard with no destination
usually
oh he worked hard yeah but you're still
gonna be right there you gotta have a
plan and you gotta have
um my dad before i started comedy uh
he's a big supporter of my career he
goes
what do you want right write down like a
five year goal
i was like i'm trying to be funny yeah
yeah but stand up is a business
my dad is a business minded guy so i was
like well he literally
had me write down a five year go just in
case
you know people get lost you see guys in
eight years at open mic
and he funny i'm like bro what are you
doing well [ __ ] i'm just
i'm not i got a couple things in the
works they always say that like i got a
couple things
he's never in the works how many times
has a [ __ ] said that dude
yeah i'm talking some of these i got i
got the script going on [ __ ] everybody
shut the [ __ ] up have some [ __ ] going
you know you know me
yeah yeah yeah you know me i made years
in this [ __ ] but uh
uh yeah just a five year goal and i was
just trying to be funny but then i
started writing i was like okay this is
what i want
and that's what i want and this one i
want so i had a destination
and it's it's so crazy how you can have
a journey you want to go on this journey
but you have to have a destination a lot
of people go on this journey like [ __ ] i
see wherever it takes me wherever the
wind blows
and you just find yourself over there in
the strip club or something like that
ain't stripping or something shaking
your ass but
he had me write a five year goal down
and i went back like
recently when i left fighting the kids i
looked i was like damn i exceeded
because i only been doing stand-up for
three years i was like damn over here i
jumped all my goals and i got to rewrite
you know another five year goals but
that's the plan i always had a mentality
that's amazing yeah
work smart work smart so you don't you
don't i don't look at anything as a
as like a fail or or you know
a bump in the road no it's a little
detour that's a little hiccup and we're
good
that's some good advice man like the
whole destination part because i feel
like even for me i get lost with that
[ __ ] right i'm just
kind of going about my ways but every
time i set a goal or a destination
something should happen like even this
podcast
this podcast wasn't so i was doing
youtube right and people heard the story
i'm just gonna tell it again but
youtube when when when the company got
acquired by google
right there was issues with um
them just putting advertisements on
everybody [ __ ]
so when i was doing youtube before um i
was doing one video a week
you know and i was doing basically it's
like a really [ __ ] version of standard
where i just chop it up and i just talk
[ __ ] to a [ __ ] camera
it's essentially what i do now but just
in a five minute format right
and that was making me a lot of money it
was making me on
average if i did one to two videos per
week probably making about 15 to 20
grand
a month so that's how much money it was
right brother we know about the speed
past that
he said he was making 15 to 20 grand
yeah just making
maybe four to six videos a month and so
when youtube
youtube they found out they're like okay
well we can't put ads on everything
right because some of these advertisers
started getting a little apprehensive
about putting
so we got pampers and the video is a
[ __ ] video of somebody cutting
somebody's head off and you see a
pampers ad on it so pampers will
be like no i don't want my videos my ads
on these videos
oh so that's when you see when you
upload these videos it's like well do
you have cursing do you have this
because they're trying to see what
advertisers they can curate
on your channel gotcha i curse a lot i
say crazy [ __ ] i tell people to go suck
a dick and go [ __ ] yourself
so let me tell you pampers ain't gonna
put that [ __ ] out hell no we're not
trying to clean that [ __ ] up
so 15k to 20k went down to 2k
to 1k a month oh and so people didn't
know this [ __ ] right you didn't want to
stop cursing
[ __ ] that dude i'll figure my way out
that's how i work like i can't i cannot
change what i do when it makes me happy
i'll figure some [ __ ] out you know what
i mean and so what i figured out was
that number one i'm still doing stand-up
i'm still booking college shows
i'm doing all this other stuff i started
bringing brand deals into me this way so
i could supplement that
so i could still keep the content that
people still appreciate and love
i'm not going to chase this [ __ ]
dollar if i wanted to chase a dollar i
would have done something way more
stable than comedy
off top like oh [ __ ] thank you bro
yeah a lot of guys bro okay continue
because i love you already right so
we're doing this and then this idea of a
podcast came up and i was like okay i
got to start flipping things up right i
did the acting i did the film stuff
what do i want to do again i want to be
able to speak to people say what i want
do comedy well podcast might be it
and then podcast is the part that saved
my ass it's not making a [ __ ] a ton of
money but it's enough to pay the bills
and do but do what i also i can get
money on the side
and so i just never changed what i
wanted to do i just kind of changed the
way i
i was allowed to support myself and it
was hard right it was [ __ ] hard man
it was it was difficult like when you're
making 15 to 20 grand a month
doing something that you've done for six
seven years off that point
maybe eight years and all of a sudden
like that it goes away and i'm like
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened no no
that's i love that and before i would
cut you off yeah
it was a quote i forgot what uh guys
said it was so beautiful he said
adversity creates creativity
and you know you didn't know what was
going to happen but you got creative in
that aspect
i just want to throw that out there
because no that's that's [ __ ] smart
and so like just to go back to my point
of like having a destination i said you
know what i'm going to do a podcast i'm
going to make it look good
and my thing is i don't you see this
room there's not a producer editor or
anything in sight this is just all me
like it's you know it's work right but i
said
i'm gonna figure this [ __ ] out i did
film i know how to light [ __ ] up i know
how to shoot things
so let me figure this stuff out and when
i had a destination is when the goal
happened
because if i was just like you know what
i'm just going to try a podcast it would
have never this would have never
happened
at all i would have just maybe had a
couple of guests here and there and now
next thing you know [ __ ] there's a
tmz even
me sucking dick on the street put some
dollars or some [ __ ] yeah
god damn dude i told you that's how it
was
let me tell you i'm not gonna stop
cursing on my jam but i suck a dick
that's when i draw the line hey yo what
the [ __ ] your morals all [ __ ] up dude
i did not see i think delicious [ __ ]
nice like that's what it is
something right there i'm pretty sure no
homo but people like we still respect
him though
he didn't sense his channel but he had
his sucking dick but
a man standing on prison yeah i got
but go ahead i'm sorry yeah but for you
man like i'm always curious too because
you you were
tell me a little bit about your boxing
life right because i'm trying to figure
out how the [ __ ] boxer goes you know
what
i'm gonna do stand-up comedy like how
the [ __ ] does that happen you know it's
it's funny [ __ ] i have so many funny
stories in boxing is so
[ __ ] funny but uh my boxing story was
just pretty simple my dad
put me in boxing at the age of like
eight nine something like running out in
baton rouge louisiana young guy
and i uh i was just i was just full of
energy so when i learned how to box
i was great at it i was good at it and
to the point where you know like when
you good at it and you was like okay
that's gloves let me see what the
knuckles
feel like you know and i used to inch
for a street fight
i used to go to school and then i used
to sit in the back of the bus because
that's where we roast each other yeah
and then someone was like man i know
malik ain't talking what you say
that's hey bro i know you've been boxing
relaxing
[Laughter]
i wanted you to say it you know but
again that was the um
but it was it was my boxing journey is
great because uh i'm from baton rouge
louisiana
and my dad was inching to go back to los
angeles he's from
l.a okay and hurricane katrina hit oh
yeah and he was like oh that's our
excuse to we about to go big he's my mom
she's a southern belle she wanted to
stay down there all her family out there
he was like listen
you coming with us malik's about to be a
professional boxer
all right so we go out there come to la
i'm sworn in wild card i'm killing in
the wild card
i go to broadway boxing i go all over
gyms in la maywood
every boxing gym they know about malik b
and then
i went to i was like man my mom was like
you love boxing but i need you to just
of just a fallback plan
so it was acting so i went to school for
acting as well oh [ __ ] yeah you didn't
know that yes i was boxing something
simultaneously with acting wow yeah so a
lot of people saw i go
i go boxing this how crazy what i don't
care cover city set it up
my dad had have the school i had me go
to school like three times a week and i
still have perfect attendance i
all the teachers just send them the work
for the week i have to do and i just
show up for three times because they
know malik is training
and now i show up for acting class well
that was i couldn't because no homework
for that so
every day we had acting class i had to
show up and i was like what a
thursday and he put me in these plays i
had to learn i was like i don't know
what's what's this about but i love
acting and my mom was like yo okay cool
i'll accept you boxing if you just can
stick with acting yeah so i uh graduated
i went to uh vegas out that's when i was
in floyd's gym
big time so i grew up in floyd's gym
floyd is my guy sparta floyd mayweather
yeah yeah you tall as [ __ ] though yeah i
was 147. i was a skinny guy you were 147
147 when i was six years old
i'm trying to shoot me down he's a
welterweight i'm a big fat boy dude
i was 147 [ __ ] five foot one god damn
you a little teddy ball out though that
was fat as [ __ ] bro
i saw those yeah that was big but you
was eating see i was an ectomorph like
oh yeah
you got it and my i had high uh
metabolism
yeah really i ate but i didn't really
care yeah yeah so
147 sparring floyd mayweather sparring
like like these big time dogs
and i didn't i got hurt i got injured
on some street stuff uh and my mom was
like okay this is a great time to go
back to acting i was like nah
so you didn't get hurt in the boxing
ring you got hurt outside no no i got
hurt
in the boxing ring on some street stuff
so we this guy had beef with theirs i
sell it
and we really had beef and i was beating
him up and it's so bad that he picked me
up
and then he slammed me but i never
wanted to like
have like uh my i never want to hit the
mat so when they hit the mat it's just
this part right here where i got
just like snapped oh you're [ __ ] it's
probably your meniscus
my mcl yeah so it's snapping like oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] sucks man i know so i
couldn't get up now
i was out for a minute and i was out for
a minute i was like
damn man this is this sucks yeah it
sucks so
uh i wasn't the same and michael b
jordan
comes in my boxing gym so i'm back in la
and i saw i met my gonna be jordan and
floyd mayweather this one time i was
like what's up wallace
yeah i didn't know what he was doing
though but you see you see wallace and
this is about time this is not
michael b jordan black panther or creed
yeah yeah i'm talking about
regular michael b jordan you have to
know him yeah so i'm like what's up
wallace
and i mean fantastic four didn't go out
come out yet he's like what's up he's a
cool dude
so three months down the line i see him
in la but he comes in with my childhood
friend
again in the neighborhood who i grew up
with he's his trainer
corey callette oh [ __ ] yeah corey yeah
yeah yeah
louisiana he used to be he used to be
the mailman he said come over to my
house and we'll box together he's like
bro you knocking you know the [ __ ] out
of here that's
crazy i swear he walks in with my
childhood friend and not only does
michael b jordan remember me
he walks in with a mutual friend so he's
like hey bro you're cool dude we talking
we chopping up like how you and i
chopping
yeah and he's a cool dude yeah and he
was like hey he's like bro
yo you know you're up next years i'm
like man you worry about that dude
listen so what you
you know yeah i'm talking he was like so
okay cool so
did he see me transform and then i'm
whipping dude ass and he was like bro
hey i'm in this movie creed
can you audition i said oh hell yeah
you say you know anything about acting i
won't tell him i was like nah bro i'm
i'm pr
i'm fairly new but you just sent me a
you know scripting up
do an audition here's our cool dude our
audition
ryan cooler and michael b jordan that's
like bro
you can act like hell he you got the
party if you want it i said hell yeah i
want it
and from that cree set i was like uh he
was showing me like the ropes about like
yo i was standing over here so you can
get more air to it and just like guiding
me and i was god
i was like bro i think if you roll your
shoulder like this and come with the
uppercut i'm just like that's how we're
like it's a beautiful symbolic
relationship because he's guided me on
acting and i'm guiding him on boxing and
so beautiful so
he's like bro do you want to box again
or do you want a hat i said
i mean i i want to do both but right now
i got this acting bug he's like okay
cool he set me up for barbershop 3.
oh [ __ ] yeah he set me up he gave me a
squeeze like yo this is my agent hey can
you send him
like he wants to do this acting stuff
he's that's how cool this guy is yeah
yeah so he set me up for barbershop
three didn't get it and i'm so mad but
uh
i was telling my mom like mom we made it
happy i'm going to barbershop three and
they're gonna love you they're gonna
love me yeah get ready for the red
carpet yeah
y'all so i didn't get that and but i see
him at the premiere movie premiere and
this
trust me i'm gonna get to the point i
see him at the movie premier creed
bob and we kill it like hey what's up
bro a long time
and i meet he's like bro this young guy
is upcoming director named
uh gerard carmichael i mean rob mcmurray
yeah
he he's uh having a film i feel like you
and him
bond i was like thank you so he the rod
we chopped it up he's like bro i'm doing
like a a movie for netflix a college
movie
you want to be a part of it you want to
audition i'll say hell yeah so
auditioned for it
blew it out the water and i got the roll
it's called burning sands
okay fraternity movie okay so fraternity
i'm out there just like laughing i'm
living
because i'm i'm like yeah i was on creed
yeah no smoking yeah
small role but don't worry about it yeah
you know and i'm with these [ __ ]
like real actors and i'm killing it and
it was like i'm making everyone laugh
there's a broad
do you do stand up i was like nah i like
bro you should try
stand up you got everyone that [ __ ]
that's where you should go
i said bro i like acting he's like yeah
the hell with that you do
yeah and then i was like okay so that
really sat with me for like three
weeks while i was on set i was like damn
stand up so i'll just start watching
comedy
uh you know stand up in my trailer and
just try to implement those kind of dope
stuff cause i was the comedy relief
in that movie yeah i tried to implement
that in you know my character
and then i got offset and i was like you
know i'm gonna take a class
i took a class i it was a six week class
i was in there for like people who had
it like five years seven years eight
years teacher was like yo you the best
i really hate if you just like don't
push forward with this
yeah his name is david davidson he
writes for like
works with kevin hart killer by the way
beast he was like man i think you should
sue stand up i've been doing that ever
since
that's crazy man your journey is nuts
it's crazy right like
yeah motherfucker's like you should try
this she's like you probably right
if i could just go and do it i went with
it i was like well hello you know but
again it was
you know you watched that up all the
time i grew up on comic view yeah yeah
yeah i watched it but i was like oh i
never thought of you know me
saying in my vocabulary i know like 193
words
yeah is it proven though yeah
but uh it was it's like boxing that
boxing gave me the confidence
acting gave me my act outs my stage
presence
and you know in comedy i was always
funny
so it's just like i need each and every
part of my journey to get to where i am
today i think
you know what's so weird about the
schools i'm hearing you you speak and
you're talking about your story right
and it's so different from when you
weren't fighting the kid because you
never said anything on the podcast
so it was like it was it's so weird for
me right because i remember being on the
podcast asking questions
and i couldn't get answers you know so i
was like oh what the [ __ ] is this
so i feel like for you anyways i mean
whatever happened between you and
brendan and whatever
it seems to be working in your favor
because not now you really get to be
yourself people get to know who the [ __ ]
you are
i told you man once you you know you
don't feel suffocated you feel like in a
positive environment
and everything is positive i'm a
positive guy i love like
thriving off of people's energy i'm an
energy energetic guy so
i wish nothing but the best for people
but i'm i'm happy because now i get to
reintroduce myself to
like the people and fighting the kids
brought me a lot of fans i love each and
every one of them
and i got haters a lot of haters the
haters they don't have any reason to
hate me they just think i
tried to take uh replace brian calling i
was like no i tried to introduce you to
malik b
i wasn't trying to replace anyone they
don't have any reason to hate me
i mean people who hate like that they i
mean they don't even really hate they
just they just kind of write comments
because they know that people are gonna
upvote it and it makes them feel really
good i get caught up in that stupid [ __ ]
sometimes too
because i always respond back to hate
comments but usually when i'm taking a
[ __ ] so it's like
that's like the only time if i'm
responding to somebody's negative
comments because i'm taking a [ __ ] and
i'm on my phone
okay but you know what i would have
started and you know it's very weird too
because
i i know i can verbally say like hey you
got to be above that [ __ ] but sometimes
you should feel good
you know why because we thrive off
positive positive thing
like positive energy feels natural yeah
it's like this was supposed to happen
but when you get a negative comment it
doesn't feel right it doesn't sit right
with you
because it's like uh that's not what's
supposed to happen yeah so
we we are attracted or we cater to that
specific comment because it's not
natural it's unnatural sometimes i just
gotta stop being a little [ __ ] though
like for me like sometimes because it's
just like i and i have to you know eat
my own advice here too because
you know what we do is in the public eye
and it's meant to be judged
yeah so we can't be upset that the stuff
that we do that's meant to be judged
gets judged now we just have to filter
out how
we should be giving love to the people
who show support the most
of course that's what i have to do it's
like if somebody's out there they're
writing these comments like hey man i
love your [ __ ]
give them a like say thank you
appreciate it but you know it sucks
sometimes and i do want i actually got
this from somebody who wrote this [ __ ]
on on a comment they go
hey i appreciate you a lot but it seems
like you only respond to the people
that seem to hate you but i've been
writing a comment supporting you and you
never say anything i'm like
damn this guy's right like i've put so
much attention on trying to roast
somebody
also to make people laugh yeah but
sometimes just giving them a heart to
show that i saw
their their their comment helps out too
that's why i leave all my videos like
i'm liking everything because i'm
saying like hey look i recognize that
you wrote this stuff and you guys are
supporting the channel
so i got to be a little smart about that
but you know like i said man your boy
get emotional
hey you get emotional bro that's a drake
song yeah i mean drake got us like this
bro
you know i'm i'm ultimate light skinned
got our legs
that's exactly what it is i have any
pants on bruh nah
uh i i i respond to everyone yeah when i
have time
negative and positive but more positive
because
they know i mean they're gonna say what
they want to say i can care less but if
you give me a positive comment i reply
to you all the time in my dm's people
know that i'm not gonna vouch for that
yeah
even at the shows i remember one time uh
we were in
i forget what city i want to say
nashville or texas
but or it had to be florida it had to be
florida yeah
it was somewhere that was open and the
guy i was just you know
shaking hands with people at the show
like hey you know because i want to i
want to communicate with people but
this guy hated me so much on a podcast
he didn't say anything to
towards me but his girl came up so she
was like hey can you take a picture he
was like nah
damn yeah i was like damn
but i was like bro and then uh i said
bro she was like don't worry he's a fan
of you know everyone on the podcast but
you
i was like damn what i do you see she
was like i don't know so he took this
picture
i was like bro that's kind of messed up
and he was like he's like yo i'm not
taking a picture so when someone else
did
he was watching me take a picture with
this girl i squeezed it tighter just
because
i messed with you i'm messing with you
i'm messing with you
i started whispering in here no i just i
just i was like bro whatever i
did defend you bro it's all good like
you know what i mean just keep
supporting the podcast he was like bro i
don't like you because
and it was so dumb he was like so you
don't even know me [ __ ] it's a podcast
bro
yeah he this is this is what his answer
was i don't like the way you laugh
i was like oh okay how would you want me
to laugh laugh regular i was like how
did you laugh tonight
he was like yeah i was like bro how did
you laugh he said man i tell you
how i laughed i was like [ __ ] i gotta
tell you i'll laugh what you wanna do
what the [ __ ] do you wanna do and nah
nah but uh
why is this dude so angry now he's just
angry i don't know he was hating
either maybe his girl took a picture
with me i don't know but you know what
you know why he hates you though because
his girl like you a lot right cause
you're probably her favorite and that's
why he hates you
that's what that that's why that's why
guys are like that though man that's
that's that's the funny thing about
dudes right and
so many dudes like to make fun of women
because they say women are sensitive man
men are just as [ __ ] sensitive
it's just not socially appropriate for
us to express how sensitive we are we
just
we just act like we don't [ __ ] care
right dudes are just as sensitive man
because you
man talk about this some simple [ __ ]
right how many times do you know a guy
this is how
they say guys aren't sensitive right
well one of your boys starts losing
their hairline and you make one hairline
joke
oh all the time [ __ ] mess somebody
gets they're like
oh what the [ __ ] it's like bro see you
justice exactly we're all sensitive
about our personal [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know tell me about my hairline i'm
like bro what you want to do about it
right now yeah
what you not now you looking at it what
you want to do about it you know what
the [ __ ] shitty thing is about this
is like
both you know you and brendan you guys
are professional fighters like somebody
say some [ __ ] like it's on site it's
like
[ __ ] no i was like joe rogan too
bro [ __ ] your ass up what are you gonna
say to him dude yeah nothing nothing
about rose back i love cause i grew up
in the back of the school bus
like i mean and i love you know that's
comedy to me you know like you said we
saw my prior barber shops
i grew up and you could see my goddamn
perfect hairline i'd be happy
barbara shots all black barbershops you
know what do you do you talk about
sports and they roast people yup
and you have this if the one if you if
it's your data just
get roasted you better fight back yeah
because they didn't once they show
once you show signs of weakness
everybody pile on yeah i told the story
on fighter and the kids uh so i took a
sex pill one time
because why bro bro
it wasn't it wasn't with my ex it wasn't
like man i don't know
am i in tour i don't know sex got born
so you know little malik b was like man
i don't feel like getting up
right so my friend's like don't worry
about that bro
go to 7-eleven go get that gorilla like
that gorilla pill
behind the gas people that's listening
don't ever go to
7-eleven for no goddamn sex don't first
of all don't go to 7-eleven to get any
type of medication in general
the [ __ ] are you talking about bro this
[ __ ] got a serious
medical ailment and you got it from a
[ __ ] gas station dude
yo what the [ __ ] is wrong with you man
it was my big bro dre
it was my cat he was like bro don't
worry anybody named dre shouldn't be
giving you medical advice
you know hey how's my boy pookie he's
like yeah what the [ __ ]
yeah it was my boy tree frog like [ __ ]
this dude
i mean i was a young guy so i was like
you sure he was like trust me she gonna
love you long time
you know you started saying stuff like i
was like i bet cause again
i think she was going like back home as
i got a pleaser
right because i was like either way
she's beautiful you know i'm secure
yeah i take the pill and then i eat my
food
and nothing it doesn't nothing happens
but i got a haircut appointment the next
day
all right i said okay cool when she
leaves i'll go get a haircut
but i'm like okay she was like you ready
you ready have sex i'm like yeah
it's not kicking in nothing oh [ __ ] it's
not like bro took the pill what the hell
and i'm still on i'm like okay cool she
bout to get upset
right so she nothing happens the next
morning i'm on full salute like i'm i'm
i'm oh we kicked in that long bro that
in the morning i woke up like what
yeah yeah yeah like it's a snake in the
bed guy yeah so i'm gonna force a little
antaconda up
she has to go to work she has to hurt
her i'm like girl get your ass back in
this [ __ ] she's like you know i think
one thing about women
when this they're very great at time
when they said they have to go to work
they wouldn't they wouldn't be five
minutes late because you when they want
to have sex they're really like i'm
on my bread and she was like girl come
on you know yeah
i know last night was a failure but come
on girl i'm trying to succeed with you
so she leaves i'm like damn gotta go i
gotta go
get a haircut now i could have easily
canceled i was like why are you just
gonna cancel that your haircut
appointment
my barber is going out on vacation so
this is yes man i know what that's like
why do you think i got a hat on right
now
my boy out in florida right now see see
upset people listen barbra
if you cut my hair you don't have a life
yeah you don't have a life
don't spend time with your family no no
i hate that
and we just talked about loyalty i'm so
[ __ ] loyal to my barber like
i'll wait like i'll wait oh bro i'll go
to anyone else you're my family yeah
bro i i i call my barber because he he's
in stocks he's like man i made a lot of
money in the stocks i was like what are
you gonna do
he was like bro i think i'm i'm really
trying to teach a hundred kids
about stocks and bonds and i don't
really want to cut hair anymore i said
bro
i'm still alive so you better shut the
[ __ ] yeah you're talking the wrong [ __ ]
right now i called you to action about
the kids
they doing good i was like nah not your
real kids let's talk about the clippers
yeah are they still short you gonna
[ __ ] leave you alone like that
come on man [ __ ] these kids look at my
hair the hell with the kids look
at these clippers now the guard
so i go to the barber shop by the way i
had to tuck it up
nah i'm still on you know that tuck you
had to put the right net next to your
belly button yeah okay right so i'm like
okay cool i'm tucked up
i go sit down sit down and wait for my
barber
you know as i am out of your next night
cool
i get up i'm untucked so the barbara and
these number dudes in there
get the [ __ ] out of here bro it took one
dude to say
man this [ __ ]
yo why at the barbershop out of all the
places does this have to [ __ ] happen
bro let me tell you something if i was
at the barber shop full of dudes and i
see a [ __ ] sexy chocolate man with
this [ __ ] in there
i'm chopping it off i'm like you better
get the [ __ ] out here with this [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] samurai
dog they killed me bro you killed me
that day bro
it was so bad you could never go back
there bro i was i had to find a new
barber because
he was like bro nah you not next until
you get all soft go outside and fix that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
bro they start roasting me my barber's
like
[Laughter]
it was so bad because then i started
explaining myself like no this is for my
girl
i hope so yeah i'm not took a dick pill
this neil you can't get up
yeah yo that started funny dude [ __ ]
funny
yeah bro and then i sat in the chair and
then after they roast you for like a
good
10 15 minutes all right come on man get
this cut and i sat in the chair he was
like bro
i'm tell you right now if the dick if
you
you better this [ __ ] better not come up
because that little apron it better
happen
i see it i was like [ __ ] making
a tp out here like you camping and [ __ ]
like you're a boy scout you better get
the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] crisscross applesauce leg
and a teepee and [ __ ] is that that's why
yeah that's [ __ ] funny
yeah yeah talking about the barbershop
but you know like some people
who like i've read that if they take
those like virility pills and
uh like the side effect is that you'll
just have a forever boner and then
you'll never get an erection again
like that's the side effect that could
happen what you're you play with [ __ ]
fire so you can get uh i'll take a
minute i don't think that was the only
pill like i
don't yeah because if you're young and
you could still get a and the only
reason why your dick's not getting hard
is because you know shit's not really
popping off with your lady
yeah like you're kind of lucky because
if that [ __ ] lasts for more than like
two days
you can have like erectile dysfunction
and never get a hard on again bro i felt
my heartbeat in my wrist
did you go to the hospital no hell no
you're lucky i didn't tell anyone i
couldn't tell anyone yeah you should
just walk in dickheart and everything
like
like help me like i i'm gonna tell you a
story
after this because i can't tell it on
the podcast but i'll tell you some funny
stories
but yeah like you couldn't get like
erectile dysfunction where it never
works again
it's happened to people before they took
a dick pill and then they had an
erection
past 24 hours and then it wouldn't go
down and then all of a sudden it just
stopped working for the rest of their
life
you got lucky well god damn guy was on
my side yes he was
you damn i was like you know what you're
just going to get roasted so that you
have a dick
yeah you go to the barbershop but here's
the crazy thing about it i didn't even
have sex with my girl while i was on
heart
when did it go away how many hours did
it take uh i think it was like a 4 16 or
18
hours [ __ ] yeah because if they say if
it's like past 24 hours then there's a
problem okay
okay yeah and they said it hurts too
after a while that [ __ ] was hurt like
that's what made me that's why i stay
away i don't take any pills i take
vitamins i don't drink and smoke
i just like stayed natural so i'm like
i'm good
i'm surprised you don't drink that's the
craziest thing man you want me to drink
so bad every time
every time i see you is like bro what's
up i got everything
like you drinking or what what the [ __ ]
no no like korean people they drink
all the [ __ ] time like there's not a
point even if you've never had alcohol
in your life
eventually something happens when you
wake up and there's a [ __ ] there's
like naked dudes and [ __ ] around you
you [ __ ] blacked out like [ __ ]
korean people drink a lot man
like i started drinking when i was 14.
so like super young you can say that on
this podcast
i was drinking when i was 14. i remember
the first drink i ever had was my cousin
uh we he invited him well we were i was
having like a sleepover at his house and
his dad had a liquor cabinet right
like all parents do yeah so he got
a bottle of remy martin we poured it
into a [ __ ]
uh bottle of evian and we drank that
whole bottle just me and him
this is like my first alcohol i ever had
was what did it taste like like [ __ ]
was that what you wanted to drink i get
well he was already drinking even before
i did
oh when he was like 13 or some [ __ ] or
even maybe even younger that
i might even be younger than 14 to be
honest with you but this is just the
rough age that i was at
but i remember drinking it and then him
drinking it and i remember it tasted
like [ __ ] but when you're younger you
don't want to [ __ ] say it tastes like
[ __ ] you're like
yeah this [ __ ] real smooth this [ __ ]
felt like bourbon
yeah man i got that nice oak barrel uh
uh
chrysanthemum taste oh you say random
[ __ ] i know what the [ __ ] i'm saying
try to just make yourself sound good i
was blasted and i woke up the next day
with the fattest [ __ ] i didn't know
what happened headache
just the worst experience of my life but
then it became to the point where
i was six foot one since i was [ __ ]
like 13. that's crazy i was a big boy
you know and i was fat as [ __ ] too so i
could hold my liquor really well
so it just became that thing or i hated
alcohol but
because people wanted to see me drink
because i could drink so well i just did
it as a party trick
so it just kept continuing then when i
hit 21 i actually stopped drinking
the legal drinking age when i stopped
drinking i was like i don't want to
drink anymore
because i got you so backwards yeah what
the hell
so i started drinking again around when
i was like 24 25 when i moved to k-town
a bunch of korean people
and they just i'm like i don't believe
in peer pressure y'all became an
alcoholic for three years
let me tell you something dude no are
you serious i drink a lot so
what's that what's the drink they have
like sake or something like oh soju is
the korean
yeah yeah okay okay okay so soju is it's
it's
i think it's a potato liquor like vodka
too but it's a lot weaker
and like in korea soju is actually
cheaper than water it is
it's cheaper than water distributed it's
cheaper to get drunk
yeah than out there and then drink water
out and cruise that's how
let me tell you something my uncle when
he came from korea so this dude is a
straight
alcoholic right i did not know this
so when he came to visit here because
his one of his kids came here for school
he stayed with us i was like all right
cool he's gonna stay with us whatever we
go out to this one dinner spot this is
place that has something called uh
in korean it's it's a it's like a pork
stew type of thing say it again
and then cook that's pretty [ __ ] good
actually like like this mama's culture
yeah i'm trying to be you know
we went to this restaurant and i [ __ ]
you [ __ ] not he sits there he looks
mad pissed he looks super upset
i'm like what's going on yeah i'm like
what's going on he goes i don't think
they serve alcohol here i was like
yeah but we're just here for dinner
right he goes how am i supposed to eat
i'm like with the [ __ ] spoon and you
put it to your mouth what do you mean he
goes
you can't eat food without drinking
alcohol i'm like and he just gets up and
he walks out and i'm looking at his wife
like yo what's
what's uncle doing he's like i have no
idea he comes back
this fool has a case full of soju that's
six bottles
of soju right and he sits there and he
looks at the waitress he's talking
to her in korean he goes she goes oh we
can't serve liquor here he goes i'm just
gonna put into the the water jug
and then it looks like water so you
don't have to say anything this dude
drinks three bottles to himself
at dinner [ __ ] crazy dude three
bottles three bottles of that [ __ ] to
himself and this guy is not dead
i'm shocked he's not dead he's not dead
and he was functioning like he was
functioning perfectly fine
this dude's a [ __ ] alcoholic i had no
idea man how does he
he's like in his 50s he's been drinking
all his life he's been drinking his
whole life and his word because my dad
doesn't drink
right and so the person that does drink
in my household was my mom but when my
father became a pastor my mom stopped
drinking
and so i didn't know that people in our
family drink because my dad didn't drink
the only time we had alcohol was when we
did communion we had wine
but other at one time too by the way i
got smashed when i was like seven years
old accidentally
accidentally because it was you know the
communion one
they would have like bible studies and
[ __ ] and the communion y was that cheap
ass [ __ ] bottle that
long-ass bottle yup yeah yep so it was
community i thought it was grape juice
and your boy said look i was like man
this [ __ ] tastes funny and they said you
know my mom was like
yeah the [ __ ] are you doing and your boy
was blasted at seven
just like what's going on i think i'm
dying
my mom said i was crying and [ __ ] i was
like i think i think satan's coming to
take me away
we're a religious household i thought i
was possessed yeah you're so stupid bro
i have a
is a little similar story with alcohol
but not
alcohol so my dad had i'm young at the
time i don't know what
hold on but very very young and my dad
had
rubbing alcohol because he shaved he was
oh [ __ ] clean shave
and it was green though oh that's the uh
that's the uh it's green it's like it's
not barber's side but it's uh what the
[ __ ] is it called it's that
it's at the store but it's a green
bottle you see a dude with a cane and a
top hat on it
no no no it's it's aftershave that's the
shape okay okay
all right and then he had the green
bottle and he walked away or something
like that
and i just drunk it i drunk it took that
[ __ ] to the head
that's why you only know 1999
i was like well [ __ ] it's starting to
make sense now bro my stomach i had to
go to the hospital i was i was
that's crazy that's aftershave so it's a
really pop popular aftershave that
everybody buys because it's super cheap
and all the barbers have it oh the boy
okay yeah yeah and it was clean yeah my
dad always cleaned
same bottle till this day it's the green
bottle dude with the top it's gonna be
sell at the store so it's like i forgot
what it's called though it's been so
many years i drunk that
i i don't have a bad taste to it you
know you're [ __ ] crazy dude
but how are you not dead this
[ __ ] over here going to 7-eleven
getting dick pills
and drinking [ __ ] barberside and [ __ ]
and after [ __ ] yeah you still alive
dawg that's crazy because i have a
destiny you know and then i was like
how are you giving you kids because i
got a destination that's why
the destination kept me alive bro that's
[ __ ] crazy dude
that's so funny yeah bro so when you
said the communion and drink
i was like yeah you want to hear some
stuff remember when i texted you right
so like and i told you that you know i
told the story
about so i'm telling this story and my
dad's like don't tell anybody's [ __ ]
names on
on the podcast or whatever because these
people are i was like i didn't say
anything
bad about the dude like i'm telling you
he's a really good guy
so my dad he freaked the [ __ ] out and he
called me and said like yo he's super
[ __ ] upset
and i'm like what what and so i was like
hey man can you just i was like hold on
a second
so i called my dad back after i told you
like hey can we take that part out
call my dad which i hate doing because i
don't like taking my words back and so i
called my dad
i was like this sounds a little weird i
call them back up and i go
dad what exactly did you not like when i
was on the cutting weight podcast
that i said that made him so mad and he
goes well he didn't say he was mad i'm
like
don't ever [ __ ] talk to me again
what was it what was the point so he
said that he came in that day and he was
in a bad mood and then my dad heard the
podcast he goes oh
he must have heard the podcast that's
why he's in a bad mood that's what he
said
but what he told me was that he was
upset because i mentioned his name on
the podcast
so he just [ __ ] exaggerated the
situation that's why i was like hey
don't take it out
leave it alone yeah exactly because i
was going to do it i was like damn i was
hitting on my guy
he was like no no no yeah he was like
for time stamps i was like all right
and you say anything bad i said anything
about shouting him out yeah yeah i know
and i was like oh i want to be them you
know
that was a good dude yeah but let me
tell you the the guy's name i'm gonna
say his name
i'm gonna say positive [ __ ] his name is
lord tony's artistic fingers and i wanna
i wanna shout him out
because this dude has been such a good
dude to my parents since we were kids
right you said that like
he's always been so [ __ ] good to us
like he always sent customers to us
and we always kind of reciprocated the
love back if you're out in the
sacramento area you need to get the
nails out you need to get [ __ ] dead
hit up lord tony's artistic fingers this
dude has been like a good staple of the
neighborhood and to my family like
that's that's one of the biggest things
right
because when you grow up like there's
always like these race relationships but
we always base it on our personal
relationships
lord tony was super nice he has a niece
named tia tia was [ __ ] dope too she
opened up her own spot
oh like it's crazy because now i get
really sad because now i think about a
time now
in about a couple years most likely my
parents are going to retire that store
is going to be gone
and that's like a huge part of my
childhood well well
is anyone going to like take over the
store or it's hard i don't think people
want to take it over you know
why because the store does well because
the relationship my mom has with the
neighborhood
gotcha it's not because like we're the
cleanest dopest store we got high-tech
stuff
we do business with the people that we
[ __ ] with right so yeah sometimes people
come in
all these people you know they watch you
that's weird and it's like because we
don't know you're not part of the
neighborhood i don't know who the [ __ ]
you are
like this is a neighborhood store
everybody we've seen in that store grew
up when they i've seen kids from when
they were diapers to when they're adults
and they see me when i was in diapers to
adults
so it's a neighborhood type of thing so
i think like yeah somebody can come and
revamp it
and maybe my parents they are gonna
probably sell the store and it'll do
decent but i think the biggest reason
why it does well is because my parents
are there
and the relationship we have with like
tony and you know tia and everybody else
which kind of makes me sad because it's
such a huge part of my life that i know
that in a couple years
i won't be able to go back to was it
weird you know so
how often do you go back though um i
mean since pandemic i haven't been back
in almost a couple years but whenever i
go back i go back to the store we say hi
to people
and you know it feels really good like
that neighborhood vibe i feel like a lot
of people are losing like you're losing
that [ __ ]
because people stay in the house they
don't really talk to people
and some people didn't understand they
go yo all these stores would get jacked
[ __ ] up robbed whatever
and sometimes it would happen until
somebody would smash a window but it
wasn't people in the neighborhood it was
like some crackhead
it was some [ __ ] crazy person you
know what i mean yeah
and we were always looked after because
we were part of a community so you're
part of a community the community looks
after you you're not going to [ __ ]
jack your little neighborhood store
like it yeah no seriously yeah yeah
because i i have history here i
know this is the neighborhood i know the
people from the store and
damn i'm making me sad yeah man it gets
a little weird because
when i was a kid i used to hate going
that struggles how to work there but
then
literally half my stories my jokes who i
am all came from me going to that store
it was that neighborhood is the reason
why i have like a strong connection with
like
blm and all this other stuff is because
it was a neighborhood that built me up
half my comedy is from that [ __ ] from
the store yeah it's from the store
going to those barber shops and listen
people roast each other all the time is
how i was able to roast people on the
internet
like that's that's how this works like
you get a little piece of all the stuff
that happens and you it builds this
weird character
yeah so i remember like when i first was
on the internet right and people would
hear me talk and the
top comment was always this right they
go why do you talk like a black guy
you think you're black it's like nah
this is just how people spoke in my
neighborhood there's a white guy saying
that
why yeah it was like let me tell you
something [ __ ] hood [ __ ] they
don't talk like this yeah
i know a lot of words like hood
[ __ ] like they're different
different hell yeah you know what i mean
like
like they they they [ __ ] it's a
different type of thing right but from
what they hear from what i hear is two
different things like nobody in my
neighborhood had ever said i talk like a
black dude
they think i talk like a straight arrow
guy yeah but when you go out of people
who don't know
anybody in any type of urban area they
think that this is
what you're trying to imitate hood news
or the
the worst storytellers i mean yo bro
dawg i try to talk to my friends i'm
like bro
cause again they if you ever hear her
dude tell a story like yeah we over
there and then whoopty whoop
is a big ass gap they leave out in the
story
cause they don't feel like explaining
everything yeah bro so i went over there
with uh charlie mayne in them
yeah and they had a little girl over
there so we pulled it off and we went
over there and um
you know over there but anyway so i had
the whoopee right yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] bro
you know i'm not lying that whoopty woo
is a lot i'm like bro 90 birds honey
i need subject predicate agreement
bro whoopty whoop and you feel me was
like yeah the whole
conversation real talk you know i was
coming off you feel me and then like
yo like real [ __ ] man [ __ ] we're about
to pop off right you feel me
yo boy came over here you feel me and he
was like coming in with that womp
what's coming up here you know what that
whooped
you feel me i'm like bro it's been 17
minutes and i don't know what
nothing happened but he fell but he
unders listen
he's so passionate what he's saying
cause check this out check this out bro
i i mean we'll talk you feel me like he
ain't yo
ain't no hoe bro yeah so we were over
there with the whoopee
bro i mean not me because now bro y'all
play that
you know how i played i'm like yo
[ __ ] don't know like that
that was how half these [ __ ]
would speak and i just never knew what
the [ __ ] was going on yeah
i'm sad all you do is sit there you're
like yeah yeah there you go
yeah you man that's [ __ ] up bro
because you got to get feedback yeah
and he's like man damn you know what i
mean you know it's a real one in front
of me
i was like yeah bro a lot of people
don't understand this stuff though right
bro like it's the world that's that's
that real world and like when
when you bring this [ __ ] up even for me
i forget about it because it was just an
everyday part of life
that's just how people speak and [ __ ]
right even when we're talking about like
a certain man coat right yeah
like you don't you don't ever say [ __ ]
behind somebody's back that you don't
say to their [ __ ] face
right and this is like kind of the rules
that we live by not everybody lives by
these rules
it's just it is always a little bit
weird to me right or sometimes when
people take you as being aggressive when
somebody approaches you and then calls
you on your [ __ ]
it's like this is how i grew up because
i can't do this
i can't say this [ __ ] behind your back
unless i say it to your face first so
i got to say it to your face off top
yeah that's that's because
that's why i love growing so i spent
half my childhood
in uh los angeles and louisiana
louisiana i mean they it's so bored out
there all they
they kill people for fun right in l.a
you already know it's the game banging
out here
so you don't talk too much that's what
they teach
you talk a lot you know and these guys
it's a code so
i know i i've seen it i can attest like
my
the the guys i used to hang with the you
know when they started we do start
talking about
people back they address them and i
brought with you all that's what you're
saying and then he even get a word nah
what up
that was it because you talk too much so
you if you don't be prepared to say
something if you're not
you know you don't say it to someone's
face and i was like yeah that's the a
lot of guys forget that code
yeah what was the mike tyson quote he
was talking everybody have a game plan
until they get punched
yeah that's that's really what it is
yeah but i kind of miss that sometimes
i'm not saying i appreciate violence in
that sense but
it's respecting yeah it's like a
personal responsibility like you can't
say [ __ ] like yo bro i [ __ ] you up on
site
and then when it comes time to it like
nothing really happens i'll talk
you know you better be you better be a
man of what you say believe in what you
say don't just put that energy out there
because if someone's gonna match your
energy like oh yeah you know
yeah yeah you're breathing fast so again
that's what i'm saying like when we go
back to that topic of haters a lot of
these people too most likely they're not
going to say it to your [ __ ] face
and they kind of look at the floor when
they do even if they do and it's like
hey man why you got to be all negative
like you know like i'm a person just
like you you ain't gotta like my [ __ ]
but you gotta do all that all the time
all right before we end the i do want to
ask you about this though like
so what about the handgun that was fun
but i do want to ask you about a couple
of things right like
so because of your situation i think you
might have a really good perspective on
this right and this is the topic it's
did you hear about the [ __ ] that
happened with joe budden about he uh
cancelling all his friends and he was
like yo you in the breach of your
contract
yeah i was like mal maul rory and maul
maul that [ __ ] was kind of weird right
because i like for me i don't know how i
feel about it per se right yeah so like
in this situation you have a guy like
joe budden
joe budden is somebody who has already
created a name for himself the podcast
is called joe budden's podcast
he set up the deal he works the contract
with spotify
he does all the behind the scenes stuff
right rory and maul have been on the
podcast for six years
it's a very long time now from what
people are saying that they get paid
pretty well
you know they're not walking away with
small checks like it's it's a good deal
um joe budden kind of has this issue
where
they kind of had an issue of like they
wanted to know well
what was the deal that you signed with
spotify and what's all these like
litigation stuff and joe budden's saying
that's none of your business like from
this situation this is the joe budden
podcast
we're friends but i've hired you this is
the piece that you get like you walk
away with this paycheck
now you're kind of stepping over the
line like where you're trying to get
into my personal issue in business right
here yeah
and for me like i i actually understand
on the business side what joe button is
talking about
i think it sucks because they're
actually tight ass friends
yeah and it got bad i know you know and
that [ __ ]
breaks my heart too because i listen to
the joe budding podcast it's a great
podcast they got great chemistry yeah
i love that [ __ ] yeah and they're kind
of going off and then dude when i heard
him just
going off on rory mall like that i was i
was a little sad
well i don't know if you ever heard this
guy named tax stone but
he was like a big he had a tax stone
pocket he was like the og
podcast and he got locked up and he just
uh
always said bro know your value know
your worth
because again a lot of people don't know
it wasn't called
joe budden podcast it was called uh uh
i forget the name it was another title
before joe budden podcast
and once he started changing that he
wanted to show like oh it's
it's me it's not a team it's me so
i get what he's saying but also he's
he's
he's kind of being a hypocrite because
lil uzi vert remember i don't know if
you remember that yeah so
he was like yo know everything no
specifics of the contract
no everything these people trying to do
spot he was preaching
yeah in an episode he was going hard on
little uzi vert
because those very didn't know his deals
he was like no the 360 deal
no you know he's going oh [ __ ] so
you know and then rory and mars just
like hey bro you we want to know and
then he was like that's not in your
business and all that so
you can't you you contradicting yourself
right now
you looking like a hypocrite no i don't
know i'm not in their situation i'm not
in their shoes but
it's basically uh you know if you don't
accept that then y'all are friends at
the end of the day
business you don't i i hate when they go
like yo we don't agree business-wise but
we still cool
no if you if we still cool you my boy
let's okay help
my business like make sense yeah you
know i mean like tell me why like
i'm having problems with this
business-wise let's come to agreement
because we're boys
yeah you know and some people like yo we
just said money is everything
so i mean you can't damn man yeah i
didn't really think about that i didn't
know that [ __ ] that's crazy man what oh
yeah
it was because yeah y'all can step fact
check you know like yeah he gotta he
cuz that's that's that makes it hard for
joe budden's case too right like you're
you're giving people advice about how to
handle your business and these are also
your constituents your peers and your
friends
and they kind of go and take your advice
and they go oh yeah you are right hey
man like before we kind of
get into bed about everything like you
started this podcast deal
you know we've been a part of this for
six years so what's that whole deal
about he goes
stay in your [ __ ] legs hold on a
second
isn't that your advice i could kind of
see it like that too yeah but also
charlemagne the guy
called it i don't know if you saw that
clip where it's resurfacing that he was
on their podcast
and he was like man i just feel like joe
buddy gonna cut y'all and he's like
y'all not as tight as y'all seem and uh
yeah it's like oh [ __ ] i called that
[ __ ]
he was like because i feel like joe
because he called it out he
i [ __ ] forget what's the name before
the joe budden podcast but there's a
name
yeah with all them on there and i'm like
damn
it's so but again he called it he was
like bro you know
he's just like yo i see signs like joe
is just like
you know he's like academics he can see
like whoever
he buddy up with that makes his benefits
towards him
and he ruins everything and he's uh like
damn and joe button does
run everything damn that's that's right
that's the clip it's a clip that's right
there go see it
charlie i mean the guy must be loving
himself right yeah
i didn't say anything but i did i said
everything dude uh-huh
exactly that's [ __ ] crazy so it was a
clip of like two minutes of just
him just like nah cause i feel like on
joe budden's podcast it's like man i
feel like you know
you're gonna cut these guys out
eventually
damn man said it to their face and then
roy and mom was like yup yup
and he's like behind the scenes he's
like he's gonna ruin everything yeah and
then joe
and then joe we're like oh you're not
about to get these guys
you're not about to get here you go with
your [ __ ] and he was like nah i
seriously like yo
look how you treat you know everyone
around you and then academics and he's
like look
this is a all y'all threes y'all three
started the podcast
and then you named it you cut the name
you said the joe budden podcast yeah you
know
ownership so yeah damn that's some deep
[ __ ]
well you know what now i got a different
perspective on it
that's some other [ __ ] yeah but he goes
hard he went hard on lil uzi vert
like not knowing what you're signing not
knowing the contract not knowing
the logistics that whatever you're
putting your name on and again i'm like
bro why are you going hard and people
when you sign that down in line that
means that that's the final answer
like you agreed to all that that [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever the terms are
and then and you got to take that and
you bro you
you know some people read it some people
are a little oozy verse and some people
are like you know nipsy
like nah man i'm not putting my name on
that nah that's stupid i mean if she's
unique man that that dude he just said
[ __ ] i'll do my own thing i got my own
label i signed my own people
and i i know from a lot of guys they
they listen to
nipsey lyrics or come out to their you
know nipsy songs but they don't live
what he's talking about they want to rap
it
but they don't live what he's saying now
it's more than rapidly what it's a
message
man when nipsey passed away like it's
just crazy because i actually didn't
know too
much about nipsey i just knew a few
tracks that i really liked right which
ones
so i mean so grinding all my life you
know
all that [ __ ] that's your art anytime we
work out you got some nipsey in the
background right
so that's why for me like people oh you
didn't post about nipsey it's like
because i feel fake like i
i knew a couple of tracks from nipsey
and it was just later [ __ ] and i thought
nipsey was dope i knew about what he was
doing with his community
and all this other stuff but you know
when i started reading more and more
about him
it was it was it was kind of crazy how
how much of in control of his life he
was
like he was an independent artist he was
doing his
own thing and i didn't know because of
how big of a name he had on the west
coast
right he he's like one of those dudes
that was doing like
that og like [ __ ] gangster rap [ __ ]
but it was commercialized and it was
good [ __ ] great music and you know it
was it was so
real he was real like when he died i had
some people in
in uh washington dc like real gangsters
was just crying
yeah crying i'm like damn bro he was
like tell me ain't true because they was
like we don't know
the video because he was like bro did he
really die i was like man
and it was like yeah like i was couldn't
have connect with the 60s i was like bro
no
yeah he was like man don't say it ain't
true man you know you got rid here
not over there yeah now don't leave
people alone man
but enough but again it affected me they
just like dude just started crying he
was like
it's been a weird like few years man
nipsey passes away kobe
man when kobe passed away i teared up
yeah and i teared up on both
i'm a sacramento kings fan too right so
you know that whole course
yeah hold on a second i don't know about
jason williams and chris webber and
y'all have
uh bloody diva shaq and co
and again i was a laker fan because my
dad growing up uh
was you know from los angeles so i used
to watch those games late at night
in baton rouge louisiana i used to see
them just check have his way with chris
hold on a second but it was a little
controversy with the ref calls and [ __ ]
like that
yeah that's true that's true that's true
but it was one of the most exciting
parts of my life right and i hated kobe
but i respected him so much because
he was so undeniably [ __ ] good
right and because for my age gap i kind
of caught jordan at the tail end of his
career
yeah kobe was my jordan yeah jordan yeah
kobe was my jordan right seriously i i
[ __ ] hated him though because he was
[ __ ] destroying my kids killing y'all
yeah
lebron every time i saw him on the
baseline he would do his fade and
somehow would go in go over i just like
it's it was everything he's a he you
know he took
every game like it's his last game
and i love that about him when he talked
about how
uh phil jackson would talk about how
every game was over and he would shoot
like a thousand shots after the game is
done every game that blows my mind man
he doesn't have to do all that like this
is who he is he has his money he has
like yo he already
probably scored 40 and just the fact
that he probably was like man i missed
that one shot
he took a thousand he's the guy of hard
work
because there's a lot of people out
there that yeah you could talk about his
luck like his father was in the nba
everything else like that
but that's not the reason why that made
him great is because his love for the
game
and his dedication to the sport right
because you could look at the same thing
jordan has a son too where's he at he
was supposed to but he didn't love the
sport as much as jordan did
he didn't love the sport like like kobe
does and if he did and he put the
dedication in who's to say that he
wouldn't have been a great himself
so when i look at kobe he's that guy for
me it's like look at this guy
we could keep saying to ourselves when
we do stuff we go oh we're not as we'll
never be as good as that but did you
ever work as hard as that person
you know and it goes back to that
destination kobe had a destination had a
destiny he wanted to be the best
yeah i'ma lace this [ __ ] hand with
rings yeah exactly
listen all fine and that was easy but i
remember my favorite kobe
a lot of people say oh hard work but it
takes a lot you want
like hard work says he's like yeah i
work hard that's easy but do you really
yeah you know many of you here like yo
kobe score 40 what are you doing right
now
out there shooting a thousand jumps like
goddamn you just scored yeah off this
one miss
and my favorite commercial that i like
teared up on of course you know dear
basketball but
it was that commercial where that nike
emergency goes down
i hated you you remember yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah wow now yeah and
then paul pierce comes out of there
just thank you and i was like yo bro
that [ __ ] was so funny
my favorite kobe commercial along with
kanye dude yeah did you see that [ __ ]
nah
where he's giving like this apple speech
is kobe right
he goes do more and then kanye was like
i'm the greatest rapper alive he goes
more what the [ __ ] is he talking about
but
he was a good actor yes you know yeah he
was a [ __ ] great he could
his speeches were [ __ ] amazing yes
smart as [ __ ] spoke
multiple languages you better make me
cry everything about him is what you
want in a leader in a sport
we're not we're not going to get kobe
hall of fame speech hey man do right
here this is why kobe's up here man
bro you know it's it's it's a constant
reminder all these like these things
bruce lee
[ __ ] mike tyson and kobe bryant man
these are all greats at what they did
and they they left a legacy behind
right and this is what i really do
appreciate and then your legacy doesn't
have to be as big as these guys but no
like we said before and we're going to
keep saying it again all of them had a
destination and a goal correct and look
at that
look at what they've accomplished man
yeah what are you trying to leave behind
because at the end of the day we're all
going to die one day
yup what are you trying to leave like oh
when they say about this guy
or this well he was you know what what
are you going to say about you
yeah that's what that's very that that's
where my principle and values come from
like man i want people to
say oh malik he's a man his word he
stand up and again i
if i'm not call me out on it that's all
i'm saying hey man
hey well man it's dope having you in the
day actually that [ __ ] went by faster
i was like god damn what the hell an
hour he was like man
i met my advertising quarter
the hour and 20 man we went pretty long
bro that was good damn
yeah man but you know malik where can
they find you they can find me on the
cutting way podcast
uh we you know show the work and toe
tapping over there
they can also find me on ig malik bazil
they can find me on twitter
malik bazil and uh yeah i'm excited for
the future
i can't wait cool let's get man we'll
see you all next time every thursdays
and sundays genius brain podcast
and peace